well here's a list you've probably been
waiting a long time for it's the top 11
worst movies I've ever reviewed I've
looked through all the episodes again
I've gone through you know all the ones
I've done and these are the ones that
just make me cringe the worst of the
worst now let me clarify what I made by
worse the worse it's not necessarily a
movie that's so bad it's enjoyable so
actually you're not going to see the
room on here um you know or some of
those other ones it's more films that
just thinking about them makes me cringe
I just want to punch something thinking
about these movies they're just ones
that like offend me that just get me and
my deepest core of anger so with that
said as I feel I always have to you know
put a lot focus on is that if you like
these movies great doesn't mean you're
an idiot doesn't mean you're a horrible
person or anything
everybody likes things for different
reasons these are the ones that just
kill me these are up with like some of
the worst movies I've ever seen pretty
much you could almost call this a top 11
like worst films I've ever seen there's
probably one or two others but these are
pretty damn close so without further ado
these are the top 11 nostalgia critic
reviewed movies I hate the most
number eleven patch Adams now very going
on about this before in the top 11
favorite reviews so I don't wanna go too
long about it I hate that Robin Wayne's
formula I like Robin Williams he's an
unbelievable talent I hate the Robin
Williams formula especially when it's
connected to a real person a real person
who is actually pretty fascinating and I
just I'm so glad we're kind of moving
past it now he's moving past it now he's
finally trying to do some other stuff
whether that are worse but I mean he's
at least moving past it this movie just
fills me to the core with anger because
it is based on a fascinating person
those cliches are so god-awful I hate
that speech at the end I hate food
professor who just doesn't get the joke
and just I do not agree with you instead
of you know like he might have some
legitimate points you know why not make
it even why not level it out that
dominant scene at the end where they all
come in with the red noses are you
fucking kidding me that was so awful
oh and just all that shit they made up
they turned his best friend into a
romantic lead and made him female it's
just ah how am i trusting a movie that
came and get the gender right or the
finger the love of the night - ooh
next one
number 2 The Haunting again I know I've
gone on about this before because it was
in the top 11 favorite reviews and don't
worry they're not all gonna be ones that
relate my top 11 favorite reviews but
again I hate this one because I love the
original and even if you didn't see the
original if you're just watching a
Todd's own CG is not scary and this is
at the time when they were really
exploiting it like hell and they really
thought any CG they could throw at you
we just look like real life like oh wow
yes the ghost is really coming out at
you when the statues are really moving
you know like they like we don't know
what CG is and we can't tell what it
kind of looks fake and you know because
we have CG we don't have to rely on
clever characters or good storytelling
or leave it the fuck along because it's
already perfect
so really despite that Catherine
zeta-jones is in it it was still a
hottie and even the woman who plays the
main Oh what's her name ah I forgave the
woman who play the leads names yeah you
know she was good she was a good
replacement but man is that a terrible
god-awful movie goes against everything
that's not only good about the original
but it's actually psychologically
thrilling and adds a lot of character
and creates a good story it's a good
gothic story and this is just like you
know fairy tale children telling
bullshit see what's doing to me so okay
I've gone out about that up next one
number not Moulin Rouge okay last one
that was on my favorites list as a lie
you know this is an - my favorite review
that I've ever done not just because of
the movie because just everything went
into it I think it's the funniest most
visually interesting is musical awesome
um but I really still despise this movie
and I know a lot of people like it that
was part of the fun of doing it is that
making people who even liked it you know
at least see the flaws or at least where
people who don't like it are coming from
I think what gets me about films like
this and some other films on this list
is when someone thinks they're seeing
something really new and really
revolutionary and they're they're doing
it just a whole new way that makes you
look at something a totally different
way but it's been done so much to depth
that it's practically in our fairy tales
that's practically in Disney films you
know they're shown to us when we're
little kids you know here's something
that's supposed to be for adults and
it's not treating us like adults it's
treating us like we're hearing these
basic fairy tales for the first time
except with some sort of modern twist on
it that doesn't even make it you know
more memorable or more new if anything
it makes it so much older and this film
is so good at that and at celebrate it's
so good at celebrating itself it's so
good at saying look at what we're doing
aren't we poetic and it's either gonna
work for you or it's not it worked for a
lot of people um I think even a lot of
people that liked it though sort of like
the style over substance sake now it's
they get more sucked into the world and
the sets and the environment of it and
not as much the story that most people
you know some people really like the
story - but for me I just feel like I've
seen this so many times and just when
somebody who does have such this visual
I mean brilliance the movie looks
brilliant and I love the setting and I
love the world I love the way they're
kind of telling this story it's just a
god-awful story and god-awful characters
and I need it when somebody is so
talented one
realm you know but when it comes to the
most important which really is the story
and the characters you know they just
fall flat and they they feel like
there's things I've been doing they're
not going say in a million times I just
break my fists with hmm just the ending
okay okay I'm sorry I'm not giving bunch
of analysis I'm just getting angry but
you're probably enjoying that too um so
yeah I know a lot of people like it boy
do I hate it and it was so tough
watching it again it's like the first or
twenty thirty minutes as they're kind of
getting into a little bit of style in
the set but then after it wears off
you're just like oh my god do they
really expect you to take this so
seriously
hmm just not a fan not not a fan of the
movie
number eight the cell and this goes back
to right what I was saying about Moulin
Rouge a film that things it's much more
poetic and much more important but it's
not delivering on it it's sort of
delivering on the visuals which are very
interesting and even I mean I guess to
some extent I'll give it some credit for
trying to go to this really dark area
that most movies wouldn't go but it's
it's not smart and it's not considerate
it's not thinking about what you know
serial killers really go through and
instead you know if they try to create
this visual realm which is so fucking
ingenious I was really hyped to see this
movie and they create the visual realm
that would actually show you what's
going on in the person's mind which is
really kind of cool but it's mostly just
there's a bad guy just evil in there and
again when you're just creating a
villain that isn't complicated that
isn't you know complex and is just you
know a bad seed even it's in the
person's mind and I get that I know
they're saying that you know well this
person is very complex and here are the
complexities but even the complexities
are not complexed they're just you know
as a guy with horns born old boy you
know just turning into the bug from men
in black and for me the psychology of
people that do these terrible things in
the film it's really trying to dive into
these terrible things that this guy does
and why he does it you know you can say
it in two seconds bad childhood done you
know it doesn't make me experience it
really because I never know what he's
like as a normal person I go into the
review very deep into that why I don't
feel sorry for the guy because we just
see him as the monster I think at some
point you see him as a little kid but
tell me what's he like as a little kid
and really what what games did he play
who are his friends where uh where did
he hang out what did he do as a child
the most we do as I play with doll bath
just in the line of dialogue we know
nothing about this guy for a film that
tries to dive so deep into him all we
ever get out of it is that he was beaten
as a child we get nothing else one of
the worth psychological studies ever
and I appreciate also this trying to do
it almost all visually you know sort of
a stay on the Cooper ground where he
look at you know a script has all this
dialogue you just rip out past the
dialogue and just televisual II people
who can do that are so inspired and that
used the visual medium of filmmaking but
this movie just did not catch on it will
felt I don't know the guy was gone for
an odd but I mean but it felt
unbelievably exploitive and not in a fun
oh haha like you know I'm really gonna
take you into the darkest deepest realms
of everything but it's it just feels
like again you know like he's just
shouting ask me what it means
I'm complex I'm tortured you should look
at me and go whoa he's an artist he
understands things that I cannot but
it's just you know maybe much more like
the David Lynch rap now even though the
story doesn't support that and David
Lynch wouldn't have like a machine that
goes inside the guy's mind it would just
just the whole movie will be inside the
guy's mind like that's going balls all
out you know but when you get Jennifer
Lopez and Vince Vaughn and you have this
stylistic world with the cats where the
shades and they look and they obsessive
with it killers and stuff I mean it's no
that's movies and you're not but its
cliched Hollywood movies and you're not
making the movies you know where you're
really trying to push the envelope you
know it with the story and the way
you're telling the story you know I mean
I honestly I'd love to see if you could
argue everybody has I love to see
someone like David Lynch do a movie like
this you just take out the cop element
you know or trying to find someone in
time you just make it where you just go
inside a killers mind well that's it and
I don't even know if you'd say it's a
killers mind it could mean anything to
anyone I mean I like if you're gonna be
all interpretive and shit go all out
don't put you know this concrete story
and then when you go into the mind it's
like oh what does it mean what does it
mean but you can't do that you know you
have to if you're gonna really be
engulfed in the world you have to engulf
the person in the world you can slowly
you know move them into it or its I'm
into it again Cooper
very good at that I think Lynch to makes
some extent is very good at that but
with a movie like this where it's like
here's the machine you're in the guy's
mind now you're out of the guys mind and
stuff how much fun away via that came
out of the person's mind and they
weren't sure like if they were out of
the mind or if they were not in his mind
or if they're in the real world or
whatever it may be they start
hallucinating stuff like that how about
the after-effects of going in the
killer's mind it's like that morning
let's better a movie right now just
being angry at it you know so it's just
Oh what you could have done with this
movie and it just came off as this
exploitive artistic look at me
pretentious I know a lot of people who
like it so if you do that's just the
effect that yet I mean it's not rubbed
off on me I just really hate it
number seven baby geniuses how could the
mother fuckin director of a Christmas
story have made this ass like even baby
geniuses - I can understand a little bit
more because there was some creativity
stuff it was terrible but there was a
little something to it a little
imagination this was again it's almost
like they just discovered CG technology
so they really think we're gonna be
fooled by this I even children are gonna
be fooled by this and just this idea
that they can just roll with this crap
innocent and poop jokes and diaper jokes
and and wide-angle lenses where people
are up to it like this I mean are now a
vanguard date if you don't do that a lot
by the way
I'm getting sidetracked arisen what I
mean
but wide-angle lenses are great I
totally you know exploit the wide-angle
lens I'm using a wide-angle lens right
now and I love it and it's it can create
so much but when you just when you're
this close and the person's talking you
know and it's like this the whole time
there's just no point
why-why-why you know it doesn't make us
uncomfortable it's not I'm a guard it's
just silly stupid and dated everybody
was doing it like in the 90s in the
early 2000s and mostly 90s not really
really to thousands early to thousands
the tilted angle which I also very much
exploit but I I try to get some
variation but it's not by me it's about
baby Jesus fuck baby geniuses I what
bothers me about this movies not only
how stupid the premises you know that
these babies can talk and everything or
if you're gonna do it make it kind of
smart you know but it's just poop jokes
and pee jokes that's really about it
um it's the fact that the film obviously
looks very rushed it probably was um and
they're they're using editing effects
that I use and you know I don't have
much I don't have the budget that baby
geniuses has okay and they're I'm
recognizing these editing effects I'm
like dude I do that for like Mike
reviews you know and how how why is it
you guys get to get away with it's like
I can notice it I know and you know the
other thing effects of the babies
talking when obviously they couldn't
afford to put them out talking so they
or they couldn't afford to actually
spend the time to have the babies learn
their lines which understandable their
babies that's the other huge problem
baby based I don't want to see children
put that much worked in this I mean it's
like I feel dirty watching it I don't
know what they did to him for me they
were fine to him but it's like it's
fucking babies you can't create a
character in a baby that's like supposed
to be an adult unless you really take
the time to make them talker or at yours
eBay big in the city that was fucking I
believe those animals were talking it
was unbelievable I fell for that fucking
ape when the clown was taken away by the
window and he's just an you like good
god what happened that was fucking
animals these are human beings and
somehow they pulled that off
so looking psychic then this one the big
thing I was saying before is that not
only is it really lame and really stupid
and technically it's not well put
together and the camera effects are
really weird it's like they're trying to
scare us half the time why I don't know
it's in scenes where it's not even
supposed to be scary um but it's so
boring it's ungodly boring this is like
one of the movies where we just my
brother night when we were watching we
just look at our watch over and over and
over it's just I think it's only an hour
and a half long it feels like five it
just feels like such a fucking movie
again the box office made a sequel
surprisingly better I guess they learned
some lessons still a stupid but it was
really tough I was stopped doing the
review because I'm just like how can I
say about this but luckily it's one of
the few times it's like oh I'm going to
a con maybe I can work that in that
really helped out but it was a tough one
it was tough to sit through it was tough
to write for it was just a god-awful
really baby geniuses
visits Inspector Gadget
and I'll just say right now I watched
Inspector Gadget growing up it's nothing
special but the coolest thing in the
show is the girl and the book you know
that statute was cool I why didn't they
ever make a show about her I didn't make
a movie about her they should make a
movie out of penny somebody make like
that fake trailer with just penny and
like you know um Inspector Gadget was
like destroyed and the Terminator thing
that crushed him like in robot chicken
or something it's just penny story what
did that robot chicken sketch and there
it should have Kefka I'm really inside
track today I'm sorry okay Inspector
Gadget you know not the world's greatest
cartoon but whatever it wasn't insulting
it was kind of obviously for little kids
it had some intelligence you know and
you had that smart character you had the
girl it was great you know and even the
dog was kind of smart inspect again
before kids you know was enjoyable
stupid person uh I don't know what the
movies trying to do and I don't think
the director cared about the cartoon it
really seemed like something where it's
just a director who never heard about
the cartoon didn't bother to really
learn much about just sort of watching
so don't god I gotta do this okay let's
try to get through it let's try to blah
blah blah um and I don't know it's like
when you're going to subject material
even if you're not familiar with it like
Bryan Singer mostly actors going to
x-men did not know x-men but you know
what they did they watched all the
fucking cartoons they read the comics I
mean they looked into it so that when
they made a choice you know they were
keeping aware okay will this is this
still keeping truly the essence of
something this clearly didn't and it's
not like it's that complicated a story
to keep following it's the same formula
every time you know if you just did that
formula in the movie you probably be ok
but no they did I don't know what they
did it they may deal hugely a car what
when did the car talk it didn't penny
barely has a role that was like your
hero you know is she barely does
anything where's that fucking bug where
it's the Waddell the watch comes in at
the end the dog talks in here well the
dog never really talked but when he did
he didn't sound like Don Adams
and he wasn't hitting his head on a
fridge what was that
did you remember that scene at the end
let's like the dog togs he's like
hitting his head on friction why you
really didn't have another shot
or you couldn't see gee the dogs enough
CG in there uh okay Matthew Broderick
who again I'm sure is a sweet guy I'm
sure he's really nice I just can't stand
him as an actor it just does not do a
thing for me every time he's on no I
can't think of a thing the closest is
Ferris Bueller and even then I mean he's
supposed to be the cool kid I thought it
was a little bit of a tweak but you know
I worked okay yeah some charm I never
saw him anything else good after that
except that episode Louie where he was
directing Godfather for that that was a
great cameo that was good
but I digress again um he's not
Inspector Gadget he's not very engaging
I always feel like I'm watching Matthew
Broderick act it's never a character
Rupert Everett what the fuck who came up
with that brilliant idea how menacing
could you have made dr. claw in this
movie with the technology we had today
and that CG I keep complaining about
imagine that hand imagine the cat you
can make like a really cool evil cat or
something like that that this is one of
those movies after they probably show to
remake they should remake it scrapped
gadget just make it about penny you know
and she has a dog you know just like a
real toy but make it like a badass dog
like uh I don't know a pit bull or
something I have no idea is just some
badass dog you know brain sick of them
yeah you can make this a badass movie I
want someone to make that fake trailer
it's just like penny you know or gadget
or whatever or peti and brain I hope it
sounds pretty stupid but you can make a
picture lab and make it pretty cool um
yeah I the CG Stu but the way the story
is told it really feels like just
there's a lot of scenes they had but
they didn't have the budget to film the
rest or the time so they threw it in
somewhere it's a lot of the movie feels
like that and just it just feels like
there's not much control while you're
watching it and there's not much focus
that these people did they must have
seen a Spectre gadget but they didn't
care enough to really try and represent
the show like it was more cartoony than
the cartoon you know I mean it was like
insultingly cartoony you know where the
cartoon at least was trying to mimic
some form of everyday life you know for
kids I mean this was trying to mimic a
cartoon world that was already a cartoon
world but make it more cartoony because
it's in Riyadh I do this movie has made
me not make words sentences that I can
complete formally in this period so yeah
did did not like this movie real
number-5 biodome is it almost films
where just when I think about an
unpleasant experience watching a movie I
just think of this film
I think it's obvious I'm not a polish or
fan a lot of people aren't um but there
was just you know when something was
popular and the people throwing money at
it clearly don't know why it's popular
how it's popular and they make a movie
on that not knowing why something is
popular so not knowing what makes it
good or what made it succeed you're just
gonna get crap you have to understand a
little bit about why something you know
is a success and I think they had no
idea what to do with Pauly Shore and one
of the Baldwin's you know I think boy
sure was just on his way down at that
point I mean it was just at the point
where it's like he hit his peak and then
he was starting to really decline but
whatever I'm sure he's under contract
they made the movie they had the set
built so it's just these two people
walking around and they're annoying
voices you know screaming and yelling
and just acting like dicks
yeah actually kind of feel sorry for the
scientists in this movie I mean the guy
who's actually trying to you know Walter
Peck who's trying to accomplish you know
that this goal of this science and try
to prove something and these assholes
come in they're not charming they're not
likable and it's just like you feel
sorry for the scientists and maybe
that's the the goal I mean he like
cracks at the end or maybe they tried to
sort of turn him into the bad guy but
it's like no this is not fun it's not
like oh these people are so enjoyably
stupid no they're just annoying and
they're mugging to the camera like mad
and they think of ever getting good
laughs then they're not they're just
niggas want to take this marker open it
stuff it in their eyes and it's every I
think one of the most controversial
jokes I had is that every time a
syllable comes out of their mouth to me
it sounds like a child getting shocked
and I actually have
in there which is it's probably one of
most controversial I did since the tank
girl joke with the starving kids
something about child violence which of
course I'm against but it's like that's
how much something can hurt baby that
your this sound so it's like don't take
it too seriously I'm not pro violence
against children I think that's obvious
um but yeah it really just every time
they open their mouth every time they
try to attempt a joke and it's just I
don't know the movie was doing I don't
know what the movie knew I was doing it
bombed thank God
feel it's the cat the movie and this is
one I got like flies it be bottom you
gotta feel it's the cat the movie it's
so terrible it's so terrible and I'm
helping us I was sort of thinking how
terrible can it be
Felix Academy would and it again just
total nonsense and noise and yelling and
animation that doesn't make sense did
not have much control that story
whatever it was it was so you know it
was hard to follow it gets sidetracked
in a million times there's a song about
foxes for a second and then you never
see him again what was the point of that
all the all the voices sound like they
were horribly dubbed and I don't know if
it what I don't know if it was made
somewhere else but I mean it's it's like
watching those Popeye cartoons where the
voices never match what they're saying
but where that was actually kind of
funny and enjoyable this was like
Satan's pubic hair it just made you want
to kill yourself watching it and then
rip your ears out and the color scheme
was horrible these creatures are just
it's kind of like in the scooby-doo
movie where there's just too much to
look at it's the same thing with these
creatures it's like maybe one could get
good design but just looks like someone
took David eyes and that's a creature
you know it's and when you have a
million of those running around and just
screaming and yelling and just ugly
yellows and ugly oranges it's not a good
color scheme and just constant noise and
you know that dumbass princess character
should be queen but again like stick
deep that title it's just I I know I got
rants about that it's my weird thing but
it's just a pet peeve of mine and the
feelings is just annoying and has that
Mickey Mouse wannabe voice and
what the hell else can I say about it if
it was so unpleasant it was so boring
and for animation that's just constantly
moving and constantly jumping around and
stuff like that okay good good example
of where that can work if it's
controlled and it's smart also Hotel
Transylvania that's not the most
energizing animation I've ever seen but
in knew when to stop it knew when to
take a rest and knew when to be still
you know it knew that during you know
the softer moans you know it need to
slow down and need to be a little calmer
I knew how the color scheme and you have
to do all this art stuff this is just
conch it's lit the whole time if you
like looking this and so that's Felix
the Cat that's the movie you know if
that's your thing
you lucked you know enjoy just don't
talk to me
little monsters I saw this movie in the
theaters let me tell you I didn't like
it when I saw it as a kid
I forgot how unpleasant this movie is
they'll start trying to cash in on that
wild you know crazy supernatural guy who
was a fast talker and you know it's a
little bit of a rebel but you know would
also do impressions and stuff hey you
know that beetlejuice the Aladdin genie
and stuff like that uh and Ali Mandela
that I feel I feel bad for how he meant
Dell in this movie cuz you can tell he's
trying he's really trying to get
something in there but it's just there's
no direction
there's no it kind of do it like this or
like that or whatever and the whole
movie sort of feels like that like
there's just not much of a direction in
it um once a lot you get a cool visual
but even then they're they're fucking
creepy for little kids I mean like I
felt this pride should melt like a pg-13
probably and it's unpleasant to look in
even if the makeup is kind of cool and a
lot of these creatures it's just not fun
to look at and the ideal spot I like the
idea of monsters being under the bed to
go under there there's a whole magical
world and stuff like that it does drive
me nuts everybody thinks monsters did
that first if there's like a dozen ideas
that did that but I like that one I like
that it's under the bed via the bed
least is underground world and you can
go to other beds or whatever but yeah
the underground world isn't that
impressive you know it's all red take
some advice just noting the shining red
light on something is not fun to look at
you know unless you're trying to create
like an uncomfortable atmosphere like in
Star Trek or like an aliens or something
like that when it's a kid story and this
place is supposed to be really
attractive you wanna hang out there it's
who the hell would want to hang out here
it's a horrible looking place you know
you know you're you have red I have
something because your eyes are seeing
nothing but red um so you got this movie
Fred Savage is obviously acting too
adult they're just doing nasty things to
kids like you know even as a kid
watching it I wasn't laughing that hard
I mean it certainly you see
starting to put this stuff together so
tee hee ha they're just kind of being
rapscallions but the saran wrap on the
toilet I'm like what the hell even
little kids are just like dude you've
gone too far
that's you are fucked up this is just
nasty I don't even think like you have
to convince jackass to do something like
that like you know I do that's totally
gross so I think of that okay let's do
it I mean they do it but they have to
think about for a minute
um and I don't remember who the bad guy
is or what the plot really was I mean
there's something about trying to get a
brother back you know but it's just so
not fun to watch it it's just this bad
feeling you have watching the whole film
and there's no charm to it it's just
angry and bitter and and very vengeful
and I don't know what we were supposed
to learn in the end if anything and it's
just this just creates bad feelings for
me all around
number two drop dead Fred at some point
I'll start saying to myself you know
there's a creative idea in here it's
like yeah okay to take media this girl
who has an imaginary friend that I think
she's created I'm not sure but at some
point whether mental or literally the
best friend is put away by the mother
says you cannot do this anymore no more
of this and and from that point on it's
a very strict life very you know not fun
stuff and a very rural oriented and very
controlled by the mother and then years
later again whether it be mental or
literally physical the friend comes back
maybe it sparks a memory maybe it's
parts a hallucination or maybe it's
really going on who knows maybe she's
doing all this crazy stuff and all this
crazy childhood insanity has come back
and it's not filtered and it has a
vengeance is it like that's a pretty
cool fucking sounding movie honestly
when I heard that cuz you keep hearing
they're gonna remake it remake it you
can make a good movie out of this that's
a really clever idea
I don't know what the ashes this is this
is like they get this guy who I know can
be a good actor that this guy has you
know he was in a lot of British TV and
stuff he can be very funny and very
clever actually even at the end we has
to do his goodbye scene like he's not
that bad um but they just make him do
horrible shit without much focus I mean
and and stuff that's not really fun for
kids it's just kind of gross for adults
and constantly making references to like
you know looking at women's dresses and
stuff like that like look no panties
that I mean just these what little girl
had these kind of thoughts I mean like
where she has this like sex hungry
addict guy you know like triple her age
that you know is sort of looks kind of
like I don't know what he looks like
just some sort of monster pedophile
thing I mean this girl must have been
really messed up to think this person up
or maybe because I think they are
implying that yeah he actually does
exist it's like a war
of imaginary creatures and so that's
stupid but I just I remember all these
visuals again going back to the crazy
fast talker who's a bit of a rebel you
know with the little monsters and
Betelgeuse and stuff like that this is
again trying to cash in on that with a
bit of an adult edge but it just really
I mean part of having an adult edge is
that yes kids can think very cruel and
very immature obviously but there is
still a charm to it there's this charm
of not understanding this charm of
learning to it and this is just
nastiness I mean just pure nastiness
that you don't like this guy either all
the other characters are fucking nuts I
mean part of the joke is that you know
she's supposed to be interacting in a
world where everyone's supposed to look
at her a little crazy but it's like
everyone goes along with it which can
work in something like pee-wee's big
adventure works are brought from the Sun
it worked uh but here is just know
they're just because they're not they're
not having fun
they're being awful also and not in a
really clever way they're just being
kind of dicks you don't know why they're
being this dickish you know maybe it
once or twice that Joe could work but
it's like everybody's this stupid
everybody's this mean everybody you know
has no sense of logic at all so you had
to have some connection back to logic
for this stuff to work that's why third
rock was so great you know where the
that craziness is coming from you know
the human-animal you know but to have
these people that are just like oh I'll
go along with that because the script
kind of wants me to go along with that
because I have to agree with you on this
stuff so we can have a romantic
connection or something I don't know
it's it's I I just think these like bad
thoughts think of this film bad mean
thoughts because it was unpleasant it
was boring
it wasn't visually interesting it wasn't
that creative
loud it was a match it's long really
long there's like three moments was
movie could ended and it just kept going
it has about three really good effects
that you know they just threw all their
budget in and then the rest they sort of
you know traded for these lame sets and
these lame they really I guess I know
he's me even more because it doesn't
know if it's trying to be a kids movie a
lot like a kids movie being really adult
or an adult movie being really childish
either way it fails I'm because it just
it can't pick a side and it can't mesh
them very well it's just unpleasant
it's funny it's enjoyable it's drop dead
Fred Tron tip number one worst movie I
never reviewed is Garbage Pail Kids when
I was a child I really wanted to see
this movie bad I loved the cards the
cards I thought were so awesome I was a
boy it was like my job to like throw
stuff that was creative and crazy and
making fun of girly toys which is even
better
I believe it needed with my mom to see
this movie I said please just let me see
Garbage Pail Kids me please let me see
Garbage Pail Kids I will die if I don't
see Garbage Pail Kids she never let me
see it okay she was pretty strict about
movies back then and even like a PG
rating was just too much that's back
when PG ratings actually fucking meant
something and I had to plead you know I
think I held my breath to finally see
Roger Rabbit even she was just like no
it'd be a crime not to show him Roger
Rabbit even though there's a lot of
stuff I disagree with but Garbage Pail
Kids know she didn't go see it she just
saw it so the PG rating so how dumb the
movie was and how it looked
said no you were not seeing this
i buy all the heavenly blessings thank
my mother for stopping me from seeing
this movie because I'm very convinced
that this movie would have taken away
half my brain I would have gotten
stupider watching this movie because
convinced I didn't when I saw it as an
adult so imagine what it could do to me
as a child this little impressionable
child that has the whole world you know
waiting for him both the good and the
bad I didn't think this bad and I didn't
think something this ugly that's the
word I can use to describe this film
ugly it every the point of the film I
think is supposed to be that no matter
what you look like or how you act I
guess there's no such thing as ugly
everyone should be accepted for how they
look I think is what they're trying to
get across
possibly with other messages that come
yes this film is every definition of the
word ugly it is the point that wants to
prove that you know there's no such
thing as ugly this convinced me there is
ugly there is horrendously god-awful
ugly in the world and it's all compiled
in this movie this is not only the worst
movie ever reviewed this is just the
worst movie I've ever seen
it's worse than nanos I'll tell you why
first off it's for kids
fuck you that you think this is kids
entertainment I mean it's like drop
different at least at a pg-13 this is
obviously trying to be a kid's film and
just insulting everything that is
couldn't decent and pure about growing
up and trying to be inspired by
something of a charismatic world
then just wants to take that away break
it over it's nyan nope so that's one
thing the second thing is that Manos at
least has the distinction of having no
budget of being made by nobody you know
that it's just whatever I heard was like
a farmer of it just like got some
lighting together and made this piece of
shit this has a budget that this was
based on a very successful product the
Garbage Pail Kids cards
it had to have some people that kind of
knew what they were doing I mean they
could frame a shot better than nanos so
how could you how could you get
something this bad how could you make
something this horrendous for the youth
of America I don't care if it's trying
to catch it
you know stuff tries to cash in Michael
Bay your money whore you know I mean but
at least again at least it's a pg-13 he
knows that the demographic is dumb
13-year old boys who want to put their
penis and anything they see here this is
for children it's it's and I understand
a little bit trying to feed into you
know the the adolescents you know kids
like poopoo joke and they like PEP jokes
and yeah the card the cards were
hilarious they were creative nothing in
this film makes sense
nothing is charming nothing is fun to
look at the acting is all god-awful the
bullies are like in their 30s what are
they doing chasing this little kid is
probably not even in high school he can
call the cops I mean this isn't like hey
y'all I'm gonna call your mom and dad
are you I mean that they probably have
jobs they probably you know I have
social security numbers that you can
look Godse here's where they live
arrest them very easy to track down and
sure they dress like you know
Tarzan meets
Rhys they wear the dumbest outfit
they're like you know like I said before
Tarzan meets Greece and and this the
woman that the boy falls in love with
you know again I don't know if it's
supposed to be in high score whatever I
mean that's like yeah the same one yeah
but cats at nine oh two one oh they were
in high school sure you know even high
schoolers wouldn't do something to stop
it wouldn't go after this boy and taking
lunch and money get a fucking job what
was it like even the plot was so stupid
you got the garbage pail kids are good
at making clothes what how what would
these things these abominations learn
how to sew who picks that up especially
looking like that and they they can all
do it what even are they are they aliens
we see a spaceship fly by butts never
referenced we never know if they're
aliens are just ugly things or whatever
it is the faint hope for the ugly are
you what who makes us states home for
the ugly thanks science-y it's got me in
the state home for the ugly ways Weiss
Abraham Lincoln in the state open Santa
Claus really it's like the most charming
I got you can put anything they put
Santa Claus in the state well where was
this where was this what any of this was
being written when any of this was being
filmed and and they're constantly trying
to like the guy the main guy who I guess
is supposed to be like the whimsical
bullshit whatever he is he's British so
he must be whimsical on a kid's film if
their logic uh you know where was he
when he says you know it's not about how
you look it's about what's inside and
what's blah blah blah then later it's
like you think they bought it
why do you still have these kids why is
he why are they still up
he'll what that they go in there
constantly threatening other people with
like a knife this one has a knife nice
that's a good lesson for kids you know
and whatever they do the typical stuff
like they they puke and stuff like that
it's one kid pieces pants like eight
times because you know the first one was
gold we have to really you know keep
showing that because that just make us
laugh it will work no more and it's it's
mean it's rotten
it's clearly not for kids you know even
though they're advertising it as for
kids it's written for kids probably by
kids fucking kids can write something
better than us yes and you've got the
eighties bullshit going out at the
eighties fashion that looks horrendous
it's all shot very dark probably so you
can't see the lame-ass puppeteers going
on all the kids look like this and their
mouths never fully clothed they just did
I can talk like that
oral puppet it literally makes me cringe
thinking about it it's just the most
awful movie I can imagine as you can see
I've seen some really bad movies and
like I said I think what projects it
into that special level of awful is I
mean you probably noticed I'm very
protective of kids I don't think we
should just like go throw any shit at
kids you know I mean I really want them
to get the best that we can offer
because they're going to that's what
they're the most developed that's when
you can you know shape them into
something good and strong and proud and
your your you get it through Garbage
Pail Kids I know you do I just get
really insulted when you have something
that's not only dumb I mean beyond dumb
but is so cruel and so dark and so harsh
and for no purpose for no greater good
nothing I yep I do a panel a lot of
these cons called movies everyone
disagrees with you on where I try to
make the point that you know what I
always say if you like a film that
everyone else doesn't still like it you
know talk about you can learn about the
person and I've heard some of the
strangest movies that people like you
know and I never go oh what's wrong with
you Oh shame on you all right I can't
stand people like that
I say why tell me about it and you find
out about that person I've never heard
anyone that liked Garbage Pail Kids I
never heard anyone knows even like it's
so stupid I just got to enjoy it
no it's it's just it's the Holocaust of
cinema you know it's just the ungodly
worst awful it's written it's horribly
directed it's horribly acted I don't
know there was effort put into this I I
feel bad for the people that were roped
into this and heads and make those
costumes those god-awful costumes they
it's violent it's you know cruel it
makes fun these creatures not kids
creatures that are constantly trying to
prove that you know things it doesn't
matter if you don't look that good or
now you're still people inside then
everything are constantly making fun of
how everybody looks they're constantly
being mean and horrible to everybody
where am I supposed to like them where
am I supposed to be like oh yeah they're
human beings they should be treated with
respect they're like wait wait but point
to me that moment what's that the
pointless song sequence where again they
don't move the mouse we even know what
I'm really singing you know where
because they sing a song we can do
anything if we can work together I think
was the song and oh you let me do it
tell me to wire and how you just once
tell me your own personal needs just
like this movie that's way it was made
it was in no no way trying to actually
convey something to
and to humanity to make this a better
world to inspire or create or anything
like that it was just ass fuck it fuck
it fuck it just look it it fills me with
such anger and I know I'm just rambling
right now but I don't like you guys
really like that it's yes the idea that
anyone any kid would have to have grown
up with this hopefully they just lived
in a naive state didn't pay attention
because to the film's credit it's not
very good at holding your attention the
only thing I can praise that any kid
that did see it just went over their
head they didn't soak it up they didn't
really read into it or it wasn't like
their favorite movie or anything it's
just because there is nothing to like
nothing I can't think of one funny
moment I can't think of one charming
moment I can't think of one moment where
I was like hey that has given something
to me the movie just constantly takes
and takes and takes and takes and takes
and takes and takes until there's
nothing left of you I do say I despise
this film the word does not exist about
what I think of this film it is
that bad so I'm I'm just going on and on
right now if you liked it please tell me
why I am beyond curious I've actually
been waiting at these cons to find out
one person actually liked the Garbage
Pail Kids movie just so I can ask why
and and more importantly how how can you
like it because I think the person that
legitimately liked this film would bring
me into a whole new realm of reality
that I have never considered that I have
never seen and I would be fascinated to
visit that realm whether it be for the
better or the worse I just I just got a
no I got a know what could be found in
this that could give any benefit to our
culture or to humanity if you're one of
those people with with caution please
let me know why you liked it because I I
want to see all aspects of humanity you
know whether the good or bad or this
just just let me know just and explain
it well cuz Jesus ah I'm not gonna
follow very very closely cuz I just
won't understand
so to talk to me like a child about why
you liked Garbage Pail Kids the month
because uh I just have to know
why is that
by